hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i wanted to catch
up on the nickelodeon all-star brawl
official announcement trailer we are
watching it on ign's youtube because it
was the first one that came up
it already has 1.7 million views and
this was only published on the 14th of
july
um i did see twitter get very excited
about this but have not watched it nor
seen any gameplay or anything just
a couple of small glimpses i always try
to wait until i have a little bit of
time off work to catch up on things and
i'm pretty excited about this one
this seems like despite what it's like
gameplay-wise you know that's a whole
other conversation and something that
i'm sure i will spend time
watching through the trailer to try to
dissect uh it just feels like
a childhood dream realized it just feels
so cool
uh obviously that was the first
introduction to smash that i had was
like with all these all these characters
that i know from the things i've been
playing
are are in this one thing what and this
is basically happening again
and we know that smash turned out very
good so
this obviously has a lot of potential
too maybe it'll end up being a hit at
evo
i don't know without further ado let's
watch it shall we
didn't even occur to me that it would
have turtles
oh my gosh is that sandy
it is i always loved her
oh my gosh it does look very very smash
the monsters i love that show too oh my
god nigel thornberry
is that his down bee he turns into a
cone
oh my gosh i just want to acknowledge
this hello spongebob this chunk right
here
is all nigel thornberry
and patrick star kicking each other's
asses this is
it's the crossover that i never knew
that i wanted and also
we haven't heard any dialogue yet just
this one lovely song
but the potential for good dialogue here
can i ride on this game do you need
writers the one-liners that could come
from
nigel thornberry in his particular
accent and voice
talking to patrick starr in his
particular accent and voice but all with
cheesy fighting game one-liners
oh my gosh that could be incredible um
all right i'm just gonna hit play from
this point again
i haven't seen any items yet i don't
think
[Music]
oh i didn't even consider that held a
reptile
my gosh
[Music]
oh my god are all the turtles gonna be
in there
holy heck oh that's some good level
variety too
[Music]
it looks like the gameplay is pretty
solid
does look very smash i would really need
to slow it down though
get out of here ign
i wonder if maybe there are more of them
that we can actually see right here
get out of here ign that
no i think this is just everybody that
we saw in the trailer
not seen anybody extra
oh it's on ps4 ps5 nintendo switch xbox
series x slash s
and xbox one i wonder if it'll have
cross play generally hope that
everything will
cross play um this rules
right now i'm going entirely off
nostalgia and what younger me would have
thought
and younger me is hyped uh
very cool and it does look good i really
would need to sit down and like break it
down further which i probably will spend
time doing but i'll spare you
that stuff um to see how i feel like the
gameplay is actually going to play out
would love to give it a try
hope i can be a reptile man that would
be that would be very cool
let's see what the internet has to say
shall we what could go wrong
neutron i hadn't even thought about that
ah the amount of nickelodeon characters
that we could get we could get
ang we could get kara we could get
fairly odd parents we could get the
beavers
i wonder what they'll do about the voice
actors oh my god carl weezer i forgot
about him
i think that's one of the coolest things
about this is i had forgotten about that
monster show i loved that show
but i had forgotten about it what else
um what was the one
rocket team rocket no that's pokemon
the skateboarding kids was a girl with a
purple hair who i also thought was the
coolest when i was a kid i don't
remember the name of that show
rocket power i think it was rocket power
timmy tata absolutely fairly odd parents
oh man
i strongly agree with this comment from
poplio 3323
this is one of those things that feel
like a dream but is actually real
they put in reptile from rugrats because
chucky would be too powerful
ah man yeah that's what i'm saying it
seems like patrick's day
is gonna be the ice cream cone that's
what it looks like
very cool
patrick is gonna get a hard nerf after
launch
oh amazing oh someone's saying they
found aang
go to 117 and pause he sees glider
propped up on the left side of the
building
117 and pause nope [ __ ] that up
hmm
i see
interesting um let's go check out the
website we'll see if there is one see if
we can get some more information shall
we
okay well i found this i couldn't find a
specific website for the game just yet
um not that i looked very hard but this
says avatar fans think they've spotted
cora
and aang in nickelodeon's new brawlers
from polygon
gamemail announced the upcoming fighter
nickelodeon all-star brawl on tuesday
the title is a 2d fighting game similar
to super smash bros
that features mascots from across
popular nickelodeon shows like teenage
mutant ninja turtles and spongebob
squarepants
the announcement trailer featured a
meaty list of competitors but fans have
been
quick to investigate information about
unannounced fighters on the roster after
searching people on twitter found box
art for the nintendo switch ooh
nintendo switch version of the game that
revealed the korra from avatar the
legend of korra will likely be joining
the fight
here's why we think that'll happen for
one one post on twitter was quick to
point out an arena in the trailer that
looks inspired by bossing say from the
avatar universe
there's the box out that shows the
silhouettes of what looks like kara the
protagonist from the legend of korra and
aang
from avatar the last airbender so where
is it
the box out ah i see
cat dog oh red and stimpy
oh my god um okay sorry among the other
characters not shown in the announcement
trailer that appeared on the cover it
looks like we'll be getting cat dog and
ren and stimpy
we don't know if they'll appear as
separate fighters or as a banjo-kazooie
style duo
well cat dog would have to how are you
going to break them up but ren and
stimpy would also make
sense since powdered toastman has
already been confirmed
and it's from their show i would love to
see the what's the old like superhero
guys from spongebob that would be fun
so many cool things that can come from
this so this is showing
elena patrick ren and stimpy i mean that
is clearly red and stippy
uh that does look like cat dog i could
see that being ang
lincoln hmm
definitely some interesting stuff going
on there
beyond these possible characters the
game's trailer confirmed a motley crew
of nickelodeon characters slated for the
battle we'll be getting
lincoln loud and lucy from the loud
house powdered toastman from the ren and
stimpy show eblina from our real
monsters nigel thornberry from the wild
thornberrys helga from hey arnold zim
invades him
reptile from rugrats to danny phantom
from his self-titled show
this game also features characters from
long-lasting franchises like
michelangelo and leonardo from teenage
mutant ninja turtles
you guys better have donatello if you
don't have my boy
i'm gonna throw hands i'm gonna be upset
uh
and three characters from spongebob
squarepants sandy cheeks patrick star
and spongebob
himself this is super cool and very
exciting
genuinely i know youtubers say this all
the time but i never say this
this is not a thing i ever say i would
love if you guys would let me know
because it would make me happy
what characters you'd like to see in it
because i feel like i'm remembering all
these characters that i haven't seen in
ages because they haven't watched
nickelodeon in so long
ooh this one could be fun nickelodeon's
new smash bros game has spawned a
million
memes this is what i'm talking about i
want to hear nigel thornberry say
smashing
what do we got okay
there's one which borrows from popular
rugrats mean format that shows stew
pickles making food
it's four o'clock in the morning why on
earth you playing nick all stars because
these kids online need to get [ __ ]
mixed the joke makes perfect sense it's
many of these characters been the
subject of popular memes time and time
again it's true i mean they're some of
the most popular characters in the world
um western world at least i imagine
but it goes deeper than that many of the
images make references that are specific
to the fighting game community
i'd love to know what the fighting game
community's response is if they're
excited about it i think it's lame
i can never accurately guess uh which
encompasses competitive fighting game
scenes around the world
it's common for devoted fighting game
players to create
detailed guides on how to use specific
characters of course or to ban a
character from time and play if they're
too powerful of course
keep me from icarly to make a joke about
hitboxes
oh this is good it's from ninobanito and
it says hey nickelodeon i know it's
supposed to be a good button and all but
holy [ __ ] these are the startup and
active frames of gibby's 6p please fix
this that's
very funny that's very good
very impressed refers to locals a term
for locally organized fighting evidence
pig means you after you 2-0 them at
locals
this is all incredible this is making me
so happy i'm just stoked
i'm i they you know what here's the
thing about nostalgia ladies and
gentlemen
yes i will keep spending money on it i
know i'm being exploited
but i'll keep throwing my [ __ ] money
at you there's nothing i can do about it
and i accept it
in any case i think this is super
exciting um hope to see more
we'll probably watch through that that
trailer and some analysis of it as well
to see what we feel about the actual
gameplay but
you know my surface level is this is
really exciting the child in my heart is
stoked so
thank you all for joining me on this
very fun journey today i will see you
all next time
bye